which aside well nobody has claimed that
there have been beside their lawyers
nobody is challenging any of Iranian
laws in European courts right because I
don't think that there has been a
problem with how Romanian conductive
legal system in the European courts when
you try to say that uh you could just
say that I'm brainwashed and pearl
trafficked me you could say that if you
went through and you dug through our
text messages and pearl is saying
Stephen come to London I want to marry
you please and then I show up and she's
like you're gonna suffer through six of
my shows now and uh maybe we'll get
married by the end and also I'm gonna
you know like then you would have a case
you would have a foundation for it but
it's not just a matter of I'm saying
you're brainwashed therefore you are
therefore you were trafficked that's not
equivalent at all here right what we're
looking at is a pattern of Tate
communicating with girls promising to
marry them getting into relationship
with them and then bring them over and
then having to do six work that's what's
being alleged here and a victim
statement saying like oh no like uh I I
you really did love me and that's not
what's happening that's not enough to
overturn it so if you wanted to make the
comparison to me in Pearl you would have
to find some crazy messages from her to
me that I don't believe exists um that
show that she's promising me some kind
of like relation with something that's
getting me to fly out here and do
content that's what would make it
equivalent the actual evidence the
actual messages afterwards
um when you keep saying here that the
judge has said that there's not enough
evidence um to convict I don't believe
the judge has made that statement what
the judge has said is you do not require
enough evidence for a conviction you
only need enough to bring a charge
forward and the prosecution right now is
in the final stages of their
investigation of doing that now you can
say that they're holding him for
whatever reason they want or they you
know maybe they don't have the evidence
and they're just bullshitting their way
through it but if that's the case they
were already arrested and remaining
before and they weren't held for that
long right where they were already
released so it seems like they do have
some internal standard they're trying to
meet to have a compelling amount of
evidence to lock them up and finish an
investigation and like I said all we can
do is wait and see what the final
results of that turn out to be if it
turns out to be that they didn't collect
anything compelling then I imagine
hopefully they release what they have or
whatever we say there was enough and
then they walk and then that's it but if
they do have enough then it moves
forward to the to the trial stage and I
just don't know why you would ever feel
confident enough to say that evidence
doesn't exist they're not going to
happen there's no way when things are
being leaked by the prosecution like
every two days every every new day we
get something else I think geez shoot I
should have read this but I'm pretty
sure like two days ago there's literally
just something new
um that was released about a couple of
the new victims or one of the new
victims that came forward but I mean new
stuff is coming forward all the time
um when you can I finish my up for you
okay you mentioned that 60 I also I do
think it's telling that there's a weird
when I try to evaluate the Andrew Tate
stuff I'm not trying to do this with
like East versus West Islam whatever I'm
just looking at the facts the case
that's all I generally care about I
think it's interesting that there are so
many of these points you're bringing up
relating to like western eastern
gynocentric you know females owning men
uh you brought up that 60 versus 80 of
who's winning custody cases the claim
that I made was that when men fight for
custody they win 60 of the time I
believe that women win 80 to 90 of the
time but that's because men usually
don't fight for custody but when they do
fight for custody they tend to win 60 of
the time those are the numbers that I'm
familiar with when you say that laws
favor men versus women when it comes to
divorcing it just favors whoever's made
most of the money and in this female
dominated world as women are earning
more and more money maybe when men will
rise up and when we divorce women maybe
we'll start taking more from them than
they take for us from us but it doesn't
matter the only thing that matters is
who's earned more money not whether
you're not you're a man or woman and
then for the final thing the first thing
you brought up was he was changing his
framework on Pierce Morgan why would I
care about him changing his framework on
Piers Morgan when the statements that
he's made about owning women were done
in the past when he owned his sex
trafficking business it might be the
case that as of the past year he's
become a good devout Muslim he's he
follows the teaching of Islam and all of
that he's doing that great that's fine I
don't care that's not when he ran his
business he ran his business like five
years ago
would you agree with what he said on the
psych evaluation that those girls should
have had a psych evaluation themselves I
don't know specifically how the
psychologist is uh extrapolating to The
Other Women I do know that the two that
go on to defentate literally have
tattoos of him on their body so I don't
know if they would be and I'm pretty
sure they still work in the industry so
I don't know if those are going to be
like the most exonerating types of
evidence but I mean if the psych if the
psych evals were the only thing that was
keeping them in the Romanian courts I
think I would probably disagree with the
judge's evaluation there but those
aren't the only things only holding him
in the court the prosecution has linked
a ton of different types of text
messages showing Criminal Intent showing
organization of um of the criminal
organization showing threats made to
some of the talent showing different
messages where Andrew Tate is promising
marriage of a woman moves to Romania um
so to say that the prosecution rests
solely on that psychevel I don't believe
that's fair
okay go ahead okay so first thing is in
terms of the contravention of the
international law you didn't give no
answer all you said is I don't think
it's a problem it doesn't matter what
you think it's about whether they're
contravened or not the second thing is
in terms of
um relationship again so what you're
doing is you're basically saying because
I give the analogy about yumpel so what
you're basically saying is if someone's
in a relationship vis-a-vis that means
that the human traffic no those women
clearly based on the leaked documents
that you are referring to went were in
love with te went to Winter
um Romania on their own violation and
then they made the decision based on
consent even the BBC woman literally
said I made the decision based on my own
choice and my own decision what your sin
is guess what they were brainwashed and
I just said to you now but anyway you've
conceded it you said that the psych
report is unacceptable that happened and
in terms of the psych report
but you're saying again I don't think
this is the problem your whole argument
is about what you think it doesn't
matter what you think
what the judges said is there was three
important level there was three aspects
of the evidence that were important in
order to make a determination in terms
of rape allegation do you know what the
two evidences are it's only the witness
statement and the psych report so it's
50 of the evidence because a witness
statement on the psychopath are equally
weighted and it's the statement of the
woman in terms of the older women being
brainwashed
it's three so it's the witness statement
it's the psych report and finally it's
the uh evidence that's been leaked and
this is the issue the evidence that's
being leaked is weak like when we see
when you look at the evidence it does
not demonstrate what they've been
charged for it's so weak it's Snippets
of information and that's what my
argument is that based on the evidence
that we have right now and the judge
agrees with me so based on the leaks
that evidence isn't enough to prosecute
or convict so that's the point so you're
right we're getting leaks all the time
and yet we've not got a diamond leak so
this is the problem we've not got
anything damning that says it the other
point you made is which you know in
terms of we're talking about five years
ago again that's incorrect we're not
talking about five years ago maybe we're
talking about five years ago in terms of
the YouTube clips that you're interested
in but I already explained to you that's
irrelevant and I think you've finally
you admitted that it's irrelevant wait
when was this camping business they're
not being charged for five years ago
they've been charged for the last year
and a half yeah but we were talking
about in the context of no no business
so they're not even being charged with a
common business what they've been
charged for is only fans and Tick Tock
yeah and when did he do his camping
business
when did he start his time in business
yeah well I'm not looking at that that's
not relevant because no no because
what's relevant no no that's not
relevant because what's because again
what you're looking at is social media
your whole thing is Tried by social
media everything on social media
convicts him I'm saying it doesn't
matter what social media says let's look
at what's actually happening what's
actually happening is he's been charged
for allegations from mid 2021 till mid
2022 is that year or year and a half in
that year and year and a half he is did
not do the cam business the court
documents say it's um Tick Tock and only
fans
and so when you are referring to five
years ago that's irrelevant so what and
what I'm saying is it doesn't matter if
he's a good Muslim or a bad Muslim
that's not relevant to me I'm trying to
explain to you the reason why he used
the terminology of property now you're
saying he's a contradiction why is he
using the term property
and and then he's having a webcam
business so if he was using the temp
property a year ago and he's using the
uh blessed a year ago yeah and he's used
and he's doing the web I only fans and
um I would call it was a tick tock what
all that demonstrates is that he's got a
contradiction in his views and I can
tell you now most people do have
contradiction the ideas what views
thoughts ideologies I accept that's a
contradiction but in terms of that
specific point he is appealing to
Traditional Values even though I agree
webcam business isn't
um
again look you keep saying I don't think
I don't think it's that but look the
judge already said the standard
mysteries of Suspicion look for more
evidence that's the reason they've
detained him no one's denying that so
you know when you keep saying I I don't
think I know you need to say that
because you need this debate to continue
going and you need to try and argue your
point but in reality that's not what it
is you have to look at what the the data
is and what the information is and
that's literally what we've got the
information according to everyone
according to the judge is that it's not
enough
um
you mentioned that um
yeah I've answered I've answered yeah
you I I don't know what to say you keep
saying like the judge agrees with me
when clearly he doesn't because he has
denied the repeals and continued to
detain them so what do you think because
he believes that the prosecution has
provided sufficient evidence to show
that there are what level of evidence
the judge has said I'm just saying that
you know if you wanted to screen
yourself okay well maybe the judge
doesn't disagree with me but it's
strange that you would pick and choose
the job what level of evidence just
answer it what level of evidence that
there's reasonable suspension we agree
that's how the Romanian criminal court
system works no that's what Andrew Tate
moves specifically to Romanians he said
that he liked the way their courts
doesn't work and he moved there and now
he's over there now if you if you say if
you say if you use a question no you
can't you can't after I'm done okay you
said you said very specifically you said
very specifically that it's about I feel
I think I feel I think that's every
statement you've made in regards to them
uh contributing with uh international
law nobody the the international courts
aren't saying the Romania system is in
violation of international law no
European commission has said that the
remaining courts are in violation of
international law and the judge himself
is referencing international law when
he's giving reasons in his own document
for why they're remaining locked up so
if you want to say the judge agrees with
you I don't know what you're agreeing
with maybe you just want to pick and
choose things that the judge says you
agree with
um I understand we're kind of circling
the drain on that am I going back and
forth but yeah no that does confuse me
so if the judge agrees with you then why
is he locked up still Yeah so basically
that's the reason why they've taken on
Tina glandian because notice that the
judge agrees with me about the level of
evidence okay so what the level of
evidence is this is that and and Destiny
agrees as well because he said his
Reasonable Suspicion my next question to
Destiny was going to be
destiny do you agree that the level of
evidence is renewable Reasonable
Suspicion and they need to find no more
much more evidence to bridge that Gap to
be honest Reasonable Doubt so that was
gonna be my question so if you can
answer that reasonable I don't know
Reasonable Doubt is what you prove in a
court to convict somebody exactly
exactly that's not what you need to
bring charges against somebody though
of course you do because if you do if
you if you if you when you're when
you're bringing charges you would not
bring charges based on weaker evidence
and then hope that you bridge the gap
during trial you I know you've got the
sufficient evidence hence why the uh
allegations in the United Kingdom were
not taken forward because they found
that the women were colluding and so
they knew that they wouldn't be able to
get Beyond Reasonable Doubt now in terms
of
um so that was that in terms of uh but I
think Destiny agrees I think I'm I'm not
understanding where where it is I think
he said I think but when you say Beyond
Reasonable Doubt yeah that's in my mind
Beyond Reasonable Doubt is what you have
to prove in front of a jury that's right
yeah so when a prosecutor takes the case
to the court
he's not going to take he doesn't take
the case based on weak evidence he's not
like um 50 sure and hopefully I'll
Bridge the 30 40 Gap during the trial no
of course he says he says look I've got
this I can actually connect Beyond
Reasonable Doubt let me take this and
that's why the prosecute and that's very
important for prosecutors because they
have a certain percentage that they've
got to meet so they know that the level
of evidence needs to be that level
before they take her to trial yeah so
they so yeah so they right now they have
a reasonable suspicion and because of
the nature of the crimes in the Romanian
criminal court system they're allowed to
detain them while they finish their
investigation we agree with this so far
right that's what they're allowed to do
in Romania the judge has looked at their
appeals he's looked at the evidence the
prosecution has submitted and he said
well you know I think there's enough
here to let the prosecution continue
their investigation and that's how the
Romanian criminal court system works now
you might feel like it's an
international law violation you might
cite article 99 and 100 and article 51
but none of the international courts
have thus far challenged uh the Romanian
Criminal Court proceeding so that is
your feeling as much as anything in here
might be my feeling
um you mentioned uh evidence relating to
women colluding in the UK on a rape
charge
um that's in dispute we don't know if
the women were colluding or not I
believe that the um prison I'm sorry the
police officer said that they didn't
like that when the two women were
texting each other I believe the women
said that we weren't um sure if we
should tell the police that he had
gotten us drunk beforehand and that the
police officers considered that
colluding now it could be the case that
the women are misleading their text
messages there or it could be the case
that the police officers aren't being
forthcoming with the text message it's
hard to say because I haven't seen those
text messages myself but I think it's
not fair to just instantly claim they
were colluding I know that's what Tate
likes to say but Tate hasn't produced
any of those text messages either so all
I can go are by the statements of the
women of the same with the police
um in regards to that
um I when you when you bring up the the
rape allegations I now I remember
because you brought this up I'm pretty
sure it was yesterday didn't Romanian
authorities find that there were three
more rape allegations that had been
tried to have been filed in a local
Romanian police station and they ended
up not being followed up on because of
the two women that were arrested one of
which was a police officer is that not
the case that not just happened
yesterday
so I mean it seems like the prosecution
is still uncovering things and I mean
like I said we'll see in a month or two
or however long it takes them once they
finish their investigation what kind of
charges are brought forth but all we can
do is sit as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible